đoàn xe bị vượt tên đầu vì đen xanh chỉ bà dây. Chương ngày 8 mốt tháng 12,
tại sao lộ 3 tháng 2 và lý thương kịch ở thành phố Chíming sẽ gần
camera hành trình chờ đen đầu. Hí đen chuyển qua xanh tại xe cho xe duy chuyển,
nhưng đen bất ngờ chuyển về đầu chỉ sau khoảng bà dây.
Đừng này hinh tại xế bất ngờ không để ý và vũ tình vượt tên đầu,
một số xe mái chờ đen ở phía trước cũng bị dưới và tình vũ này.
Các nghĩ định một chăm sóm biết tám trên 2 người khu trăm 20 tư,
hành vi vượt tên vào hoặc đó sẽ bị phạt bốn đen xao sự đồng vượt xe mái,
và mùi tâm đến 2 mi trượng đồng vượt tốt,
chương bốn đếm dưới phép lại xe.
Tuy vậy, theo vui trình bốn mốt hai người khu trăm hai người tư bê ở tè vê tê,
hợi lực từ ngày 1 mốt tháng 1 năm hai người khu trăm hai người lắm,
thời gian đen xanh tối thiệu cho một hướng gió thông ít đạm người làm dây.
Đừng này có nghĩa đen xanh trong kính vũ trên chưa đáp ứng thời gian tối thiệu của kuy trình.
Hí bị phạt vượt, người điều tốt,
xem mai có thể cũng có video từ camera hành trình đề sắp mình tình hốn.
Nếu không có video, có thể đưa ra dịch cho những nghi ngờ về việc camera không đủ thời gian cần thiết,
và yêu cầu cạnh bộ chức năng cho xem hại cả video dài từ camera giám sát sát sát thông.